未成年の皆さん
酔っ払ったことありますか？
いや、あっちゃだめだわｗｗｗ
あっちゃだめだわｗ
酔っ払ったこと無いと思います
お酒は二十歳になってからなんで
酔っ払ったこと無いと思うんですけども
今回ですねぇ
すごいものを買ってみました
うわー小さい、うわぁ
えぇ？怖い
はい今回こちら！
FATAL VISION
えーと、これですねぇ
あはっｗ
なんだっけこれ
あっ、そうそうちゃんとあった
これゴーグルなんですけどなんとこれ！
飲酒状態体験ゴーグルっていう
なんか飲酒してる状態を体験できるゴーグルらしいです
つまりこれさえあればですね
未成年の皆さん
これをかけることによって、あの
大人の人たちは
おじちゃんおばちゃんたちは
お酒を飲んだらなんかいつも変なことを喋って
ふらふらしててちょっと
ばかっぽいけどｗ
どんな状態なんだろうっていうのをね
これをつけることによって体験することができます
飲酒状態体験ゴーグル
これの目的は
要するにこれをかけることによって
飲酒の危険性をね、感じられるらしいです
僕もお酒弱いんで結構ふらふらするんですけども
大抵どういう、どういう状況なのかっていうのが
覚えてられないんで今回ちょっと
実際これをつけてみようって話ですよ
うわぁぁ待って
やばい
おお～
これをつけるともうね酔った状態の
視覚になるらしいです
早速ちょっとつけてみましょう
あっ
3万円です
高くないかぁぁあ?!
1回つけてみましょう
1回ちょっとつけてみますね
おぉぉぉぉあ!!
あーーー！
うわー！うわーこれ
うわーっわーわー
なんかチラチラチラ‥
チラチラする
なんかチラチラしてよくわかんない
うわ、きもっちわるぅ！！
うわっうわぁ”
これっ、うわっ
ほんとに、こんな感じだわ
うわぁ、すっぐわぁ、うわぁ‥
っすげぇ
再現度がすごい
わぁ、今もねちょっと気持ち悪くなりましたもん
そうだなぁ、なんか酔ったときはこんな感じだった気がするよ
皆さんにも体感させてあげよう
つけるとこんな感じ･･･
全然分かんねぇな
これ多分ねぇ
ちょー酔ってる状態ですね
だいぶ酔ってる時だとこんな感覚なんだと思います
1回ちゃんと歩けるかやってみます
うわっ、うわぁ！
うわ、これやばいやばい！
え、すごいこれ
あーでもなんか似てるわーなんかねー
こんな感じにふらふらした覚えはありますわでも
ふっふーんふっふー（もぐもぐしながら）
後輩）あーそういうことか
は）やばくない？
後輩）やばいっすこれｗ
は）ちょっ、顔面白いんだけどｗ
は）まって、なんか、はっはっはｗｗｗ
まってまってｗｗｗｗ
は）なんか顔が変だよぉｗｗｗ
後輩）えぇ？？
は）え、待ってどうなってんのこれ
後輩）心なしか吐き気が･･･
後輩）ｹﾞｯﾎｹﾞﾎ
は）ちょ、ちょっと歩いてみて
は）ドア出て歩いてみて
（カスッｗｗ）
は）はっはっｗｗ
後輩）え･･･?
（ドンッ）
は）ふっふっふｗｗｗ
（何かに足をぶつける音）
は）うわっやばいっ！！！！(叫)
（ﾁｰｰｰｰｰｰﾝ）
はい。というわけでこれ
つけてるだけでもめちゃくちゃほんとに
視界が悪くて
物の感覚とかわかんないんすよ
今回はその
酔った、泥酔してる状態の自分のさらに上に行くために
ここからさらに100回回転してからこれをつけると
どうなってるのか
もう泥酔の上ですから
普通の人間だと味わうことのできない感覚に
達すると思うんですよ
じゃあ100回回ります
後輩）100！
は）おっけ！いくよ？
は）まって･･･
は）ちょっとまってまってまってってｗｗｗ
は）うわ！うわまって、まって
は）つけるとこから始まりますからね勝負は
は）うーわぁ！
は）まって･･･
（よろけて）
（ぶつけて）
（転ぶ）
♪エンディング♪
みなさん
お酒には気をつけましょう
じゃあな！